so Dark Souls 2 came out in the spring
of 2014 we're in the fall now there's
already been two DLC Packs you just got
a chance to play the third one though
we're at Namco Bandai for TGs I was busy
in a meeting room but what are your
thoughts on it for anyone who's a
hardcore Dark Souls fan uh this is the
third one now and you're into the exact
same stuff that you know and love in the
dark souls Series this is actually the
largest world for a DLC that they've
made so far so it's a really big
expansive world and there's snow now so
uh it's interesting it actually does
impact the game play in various ways uh
it can actually slow down enemies and uh
it can impact you as well so you have to
be a little bit more fluid they said in
terms of like fighting mechanics they
wanted to have a little bit more
fluidity into the way that you're
playing so they want um you to be very
careful with your movement so that you
can kind of use that snow to your
advantage another thing is is that a lot
of the monsters are made of ice or
they're white uh what that ends up
meaning is that they kind of sneak up on
you and they can they can kind of jump
up on you and and surprise you so um you
know that's kind of the Dark Souls way
right is that they put you in precarious
situations if you're not being careful
and this new DLC it's no exception they
are incredibly well hidden and if you're
not being careful they will kill
you
[Music]
one thing I asked them about it cuz they
mentioned snow and I was wondering cuz
they were saying it's going to like
impact enemies and stuff I asked them if
it accumulated on the ground and it
doesn't right it's just sort of like in
the air and like but it comes in
different strengths like they they
different moments where it's it's pretty
dense and maybe has a stronger effect on
enemies yeah that's right um and you
know there's times when it's falling
from the sky and then there's times when
it's not when it is falling from the sky
a lot of times again they'll be
peripherals they'll be harder to see so
it's something you really need to to
keep in mind um that the terrain and the
environment are a little bit more
impactful in your gameplay than it has
been in the past two DLCs it is a really
nice new way to enjoy the series so
you're trying to get another one of
those crowns right yes that's correct so
this is the crown of the ivory King and
uh well we always ask you know hey
what's going to happen when you get
those crowns they've a little bit closed
lift about what's going to happen but
they had said for anyone who is a
hardcore fan of the series it's going to
give you a pretty cool Power something
that people are really going to be
excited about especially people that are
um going to go through all the effort of
making sure that they get those crowns
they're going to be heavily rewarded
with something that is exclusive to them
and I think that's going to be really
cool to find out what it
is